non-minimalists
much of what you talk about with
minimalism
such as not relying on material goods
for commitment of contentment or living
in the present moment
without being reactionary i strongly
identify with as i've grown up
practicing buddhism
and i was wondering if you've ever
written or spoken about the similarities
between
buddhism and minimalism you know what's
fascinating ryan and i have been on nine
tours in the last 10 years we've got on
book tours or or
film tours and people come up to us in
like the hug line afterward which can
you imagine
hug lines we used to hug people you guys
remember that
uh uh and anyway people will come up to
us and they say
hey you know it's so great to see two
guys out here spreading jesus's message
and i'm like hey thanks really
appreciate that next person you know
10 people later next tour stop hey it's
really great to see a couple buddhists
out here
just spreading the good word and then
someone else you know later in
that month will be like hey did you guys
know that muhammad was the original
minimalist and and it's like oh cool
and so you know i think what happens is
we take our belief system and then we
sort of map it on to to something else
but but
um yes i think a lot of a lot of
religions
or you could go even go back to stoics
or whoever
they did talk about as julianne said not
relying on material goods for our
contentment however it doesn't mean that
we're allergic to material goods either
yeah i think that for me uh early on in
my life i was very much a monastic
everything i owned i could put into one
paper bag
wow and so one way before it was
um novel uh or uh
something of cultural interest or
intrigue i was i was like this
and so when my wife and i were married i
wouldn't even buy us a bed i slept on
the floor
and i told that that a bed was a luxury
not a necessity
sorry i still still blows my mind to
keep going so when people talk about
minimalism
i lived at an extreme level of
minimalism for many many years
and i i only worked enough to eat
and which yeah it wasn't it wasn't
always a good ratio some days i didn't
even have
the money to eat i i would wait to wash
clothes and
and until i had enough change to wash
clothes i mean i was
truly minimal and i
moved across the country i got a ride
with someone that didn't have a car
i didn't own anything and he said well i
don't have enough room in my car for you
and i
and i said oh for your luggage i said i
don't have any luggage
and uh moved across the country i had no
place to live no job no food
nothing but the clothes i have is pretty
much what i wore and
and but i i but a huge part of me was
i despised the material world
and i don't think i had a healthy
relationship with with creation because
creation nature is a part of the of the
of the
material world and i and i i
feel like i didn't understand that um
enjoying this life was not an evil
yes i had to come to a place where i
i wasn't owned by things but but i could
celebrate
the beauty of things and i and i did
have to go through an evolution of that
i had to go through
a season i remember when i went to this
pastor that knew me when i was brand new
in my faith because i became a follower
of jesus as an adult
and i said i'm thinking about getting
married and i introduced them to kim and
he told me kim is perfect for you
because she was an orphan
she lived in poverty she was left
starving for several weeks when she was
a child at the age of eight
and that was the negative side of
minimalism yeah and
he said you would never have anything in
your life but because you love her
you're going to
you're going to get things simply to
take care of her wow
and i realize that also there's an
expression of love
that teaches you how to relate to things
and i think in a healthy way
right and i think that's the key it's in
a healthy way because i grew up
really poor in dayton ohio food stamps
government assistance
and that wasn't minimalism for me
because it wasn't intentional right
and so what we're talking about now is
is bringing things into our lives
intentionally and and the things that
add value questioning the things i think
that's become the problem with
consumerism there's nothing inherently
wrong with consumption we all need some
stuff
but when it becomes the driver for
everything that we do
we start to to lose sight now aaron how
did this
rub off on you growing up
underneath erwin's rain his tyrannical
reign of not owning things
you were you were different growing up
because i think you were kind of in this
place where you know
we were definitely wealthy but but you
were but
we always had everything we needed like
i always remember having clothes
remember never being really hungry but
but i
but also like as i got older and
obviously living in l.a like you realize
okay the disparity and wealth of the
disparity and like
lifestyle and as we grew and as you
wrote books and as things kind of
got more successful i realized like it's
super easy to get caught up in like what
car do i drive
where do i live what's the zip code you
know go where do i go out to eat where
do i do this and i think for us it was
a huge conversation of like what's the
life that style that you can obtain or
can
achieve and live at or where do you
actually feel like you're making the
most
effect in the world and bringing the
most change and actually doing things so
it was less about
how much stuff and then what what are
you doing with the things that you
actually do have
and he you always taught me that it's
always what you have inside of you
than than the things that you can hold
with your hands and so
you know i do drive a good car now but
but i but i drove the same
mini cooper until i wrecked it for for
however long that i
i could and and they were they're things
that
i grew up without but i also never felt
like i needed
and so to see it now i think it helps me
with my world view of going like i can
be anywhere and
be comfortable i can go to to to
to a place of luxury or a place of of
poverty and go like i feel at home
because it's joy that i value and it's
kindness and it's
sometimes not always kindness working on
being kinder but but
there's these attributes of
characteristics of like a people's
personality i think that
i care about more than things i think
that what's fascinating is
you talked about there's nothing wrong
with with pleasure um
and i agree with that as long as it
doesn't get in the way of our actual
contentment or joy right and i think one
of the problems right now is we confuse
pleasure we confuse the dopamine rush
with
everlasting joy or contentment or even
happiness which is also fleeting but
i think is a byproduct of something
healthier than just pure
hedonistic pleasure right now or when i
heard you mention on a recent episode of
of the battle ready podcast we'll put a
link to the podcast in the show notes
for folks who want to check it out uh
you talked about money versus
freedom and i thought this was
applicable to julianne's question here
where actually do you want to riff on
that a little bit that's interesting
thank you for listening now i know you
actually listen to the podcast
no and yeah i i think a lot of people
um well i i just had knee surgery so
um during the quarantine i had a couple
of accidents when i busted my face open
so i had 15 stitches in my face
and uh and then i uh blew out my knee
so i had to have knee surgery and so
i've been going through physical therapy
and um
i have a young guy who's japanese who's
my therapist and as we began talking he
said man i'm just
i'm just driven by things whenever i'm
going through therapy i end up doing
therapy for people i mean
it's always like this and so he
he said i feel like i'm i i'm greedy i
just want more and whenever i have
something i want more and i'm never
satisfied and
and so i said as he was trying to help
me you know retrain my knee
i said your problem is that you're more
driven by my money than you are by
freedom
and and like i said look i can tell you
i've been extremely poor and i've been
extremely wealthy i i've had the
spectrum
of of that human experience and
um i i feel most content when i feel
that i've attained a freedom to be who i
who i long to be
and to express my life the way i long to
live it and
there there is this odd illusion that
more gives you more freedom
but there's actually a break point where
if you're driven by more you lose all
your freedom
yeah and it's this whole idea of living
for retirement i mean what an idiotic
idea yes right to work all of your life
at a job you hate
so that you can vacate it when you don't
have the energy to live the life you
longed for yeah and and so i i just
think it's a
it's a good measuring point to go uh
well if i were completely free like i've
asked people if you had
all the money in the world what would
you want your life to look like
and they normally say i don't know and
so i said okay here's the problem
you're trying to to get more wealth to
live a life
you don't even know what it looks like
so
so you're actually living an illusion of
what other people tell you
that if you can attain you will finally
be happy
and so you need to in my life i find
incredible joy
when my family is able to
uh you know enjoy each other and love
each other and have time together and
when we're able to have conflict at a
minimal level and and and everyone's
has a sense of meaning and intention in
their life
it isn't measured by money no and and
we've had those moments when we had less
money we've had those moments and we've
had more money
that's why i don't see money as the is
the enemy
of of contentment i think greed is the
enemy of contentment
yeah and uh and i i see money as a
resource just like if
you know the other day um i i cooked um
six whole chickens and uh and six
racks of ribs i took on my birthday i
decided to cook all day
and because i thought what would be the
most enjoyable thing during my birthday
and i said
like feeding people like doing working
all day to create a beautiful experience
for people
and i think if we just shift our lives
to like the celebration of me
isn't everybody bringing me something a
celebration of me is me bringing
something to everybody and that's what i
i would love for people to kind of
see that really what you want to do is
you want to be in that that pocket
where um you're actually
position to live freely being the person
you long to be
and your resources become a conduit of
all the good you long to do
yes well julianne i hope i hope we can
send you a copy of
one of irwin's books what book should we
send her
well i think maybe the way the warrior
soul cravings maybe yeah
okay maybe it's so crazy we'll figure it
out well aaron will pick it out
i'm gonna send you one actually so
cravings would be good
you